meravigliati
stupefatti senza parole senza fiato
quando lui ci troviamo di fronte alle
dolomiti le espressioni che descrivono
il nostro stato sono espressione che
rimandano una specie di scacco matto
come se ci venisse incontro qualcosa che
è più grande di noi qualcosa che ci
trascende e di fronte al quale noi
possiamo utilizzare solitamente un
aggettivo soltanto vale a dire
bellissimo ma che cos'è quella bellezza
che le dolomiti da sempre regalano al
passante al viandante che osa calpestare
queste cime che cosa significa davvero
quella bellezza perché deve essere
qualcosa di più di una semplice
rispondenza tra il mio gusto personale e
quello che vedo deve essere qualcosa di
più rispetto a un mi piace è una specie
di folgorazione totale una specie di
vero e proprio innamoramento nei
confronti della realtà e allora ecco che
la bellezza nelle dolomiti si disvela in
un modo molto più profondo di un
semplice gusto è qualcosa di molto di
più è una specie di rivelazione di
qualcosa di ulteriore che sta dentro la
realtà è che ci viene incontro
attraverso il simbolo della bellezza
insomma la bellezza delle dolomiti è il
modo di manifestarsi dell'assoluto ecco
perché rimaniamo senza fiato
ecco perché da sempre storicamente le
dolomiti sono state calamità e scrigno
per uomini amanti della bellezza
ecco perché le dolomiti sono state così
amate così rivalutate nel periodo del
romanticismo ed ecco forse perché di
fronte a questo spettacolo di fronte a
questa vera e propria meraviglia viene
incontro a noi nuovamente l'essenza
dello spirito romantico l'essenza del
romanticismo
infatti l'essenza del romanticismo sta
forse proprio tutta qua nel poter
riscoprire un senso della bellezza in
chiave profonda come manifestazione
dell'assoluto
non è un caso che molto spesso questo
senso della bellezza questo senso dei
significati simbolici e nascosti che
stanno dentro la realtà ma che non ci
vengono incontro in prima istanza sia
stato un significato che e stato
affidato nel corso del tempo a miti e
fiabe e parallelamente proprio le
tradizioni montane proprio le tradizioni
di montagna compresa la tradizione delle
dolomiti hanno avuto sempre a che fare
con la trasmissione di queste antiche
storie fiabe e miti fiabe miti che sono
come ci ricorda lo psicanalista carl
gustav jung molto di più di semplici
racconti di analfabeti di fronte a foto
sono in realtà degli scrigni che
racchiudono antiche sapienze significati
che potremmo definire
archetipici cioè che hanno a che fare
con elementi essenziali della nostra
coscienza quando noi raccontiamo un mito
quando riprendiamo una fiaba dell'antica
tradizione abbiamo a che fare con
significati profondi della nostra psiche
questi significati profondi che ci
appartengono
sono proprio gli stessi che ci vengono
incontro quando rimasti senza fiato e
folgorati di fronte alle dolomiti noi
diciamo di essere senza parole o senza
respiro
proprio perché quel paesaggio e
mozzafiato
cioè ci toglie la capacità di respirare
la montagna in fondo a questa
straordinaria e apparentemente
paradossale capacità cioè da un lato di
mostrarci radicalmente e in maniera
ineludibile il fatto che noi siamo
creature piccole e finite
ogni volta che tentiamo di scalarle ogni
volta che ci confrontiamo rispetto alla
loro mastodontica magnificenza ogni
volta che noi cerchiamo di osservarle
siamo colpiti da quello splendore
noi comprendiamo nella montagna la
nostra finitezza di esseri umani
eppure la comprendiamo perché si
manifesta all'assoluto e così guardando
le dolomiti se da un lato ci sentiamo
infinitamente piccoli dall'altro però
abbiamo la percezione di una infinita
che ci appartiene proprio in quanto
creature finite il basso e l'alto il
verticale e orizzontale la terra e il
cielo gli opposti che sembrano unirsi
ogni qualvolta il viandante osa sfidare
le altezze inerpicandosi sui crinali
questo è lo spirito della montagna e per
questo motivo le dolomiti da sempre sono
scrigno di leggende di sapienza per
viaggiatori e per spiriti essenzialmente
romantici molte sono le leggende che
abitano queste cime una delle più
celebri ambientata non distante da qui
ci racconta di come una regina sorta
dalla bellezza del paesaggio di nome
dolasilla con la sua straordinaria
bellezza poter pacificare un paesaggio
altrimenti abitato da mostri grazie alla
forza della sua sapienza ed è molto di
più di una piccola storia è appunto un
archetipo l'archetipo della bellezza
femminile che si incarna nella natura ed
è un archetipo che ricorre in molti miti
molte fiabe si pensi alla sibilla
appenninica sui monti sibillini
nelle marche si pensi alla venus alla
venere
che è nascosta nel venusberg nella
leggenda del turn over
si tratta sempre di uno spirito
femminile che custodito nella montagna
viene a raccontare quanto viene la
natura di assoluto di sacro e di
meraviglioso quindi capita bene che
quando noi siamo di fronte a miti e
fiabe quello che ci viene incontro è
molto di più di un semplice dello stesso
mann di un semplice racconto è una
sapienza perduta e riscoperta attraverso
racconti atavici che ci riguardano in
quanto esseri umani questa è la voce
della montagna e in questo senso non è
un caso che quegli spiriti romantici
attratti dalle dolomiti nel corso del
tempo e che a tutt'oggi vengono
calamitati a questa bellezza per la
sensibilità del proprio spirito non è un
caso che proprio il romanticismo si è
andato a interessarsi di quelle fiabe
riscoprendo le riportandole alla
modernità antichi racconti per tutti che
ritornavano attuali wolf hall ha fatto
in queste zone
parlando del regno dei fans di molte
altre leggende ma parallelamente circa
negli stessi anni i fratelli grimm in
germania william butler yeats l'irlanda
puskin in russia tutti spiriti affini
che in quel periodo storico andavano a
recuperare qualcosa di sepolto
nell'inconscio collettivo dell'europa
attraverso la riscoperta di antiche
fiabe perché non per raccontare di nuovo
storie non soltanto ma soprattutto per
riscoprire un senso profondo dell'uomo
legato al romanticismo noi oggi siamo di
fronte alle dolomiti alla loro bellezza
e dobbiamo e non possiamo fare
altrimenti sentirci romantici ma
romantico è qualcosa di più di un
semplice movimento letterario e
filosofico che si è sviluppato in
inghilterra in germania tra sette e
ottocento e assolutamente ben poco a
vedere con quel senso smielato e
sdolcinato da baci perugina che noi
siamo abituati attribuire a questa
parola romantico è una modalità di
essere uomini
una capacità antropologica un modo di
essere nei confronti del mondo si è
romantici perché ci si pone in un certo
specifico atteggiamento rispetto alla
realtà e oggi specialmente oggi in un
mondo che per molti versi e dopo la
deriva tecnologica vuole ritornare ad e
scoprire che cosa significa essere uomo
un mondo globalizzato e interconnesso
dove il senso antropologico profondo
della nostra umanità pare dissolversi
proprio oggi forse il romanticismo
ancora da dirci qualcosa di essenziale
di decisivo di profondo perché molto è
stato dimenticato ma molto può essere
recuperato proprio con questa attitudine
se ci pensiamo attentamente essere
romantici non è una cosa astratta è un
modo di essere una modalità ontologica è
il nostro modo il nostro portamento
sulla terra se si è romantici è
difficile che non vi siano delle buone
maniere una sorta di naturale cortesia a
regolare i rapporti tra gli uomini
e allora sarà difficile che una parola
sgarbata o un atto di crudeltà
intercorre tra diverse creature
se siamo romantici come gli antichi
romantici noi percepiamo la bellezza
sacrale ieratica della natura e quando
qualcosa è sacro lo si rispetta per
forza quindi è molto difficile compiere
scempi architettonici o persino buttare
una cartaccia se siamo romantici noi
crediamo nei sogni non ci fermiamo alla
realtà e ricerchiamo quell'assoluto del
quale la natura con la sua bellezza
incessantemente ci parla quindi essere
romantici e questa ispirazione ci è data
dalle dolomiti è un modo di rivolta nei
confronti del mondo moderno è una sorta
di risposta al fatto che stiamo qua e
non abbiamo la capacità di descrivere
l'emozione il sentimento che ci rende
presente in questo momento non è un caso
che gli antichi romantici amassero tanto
venire le dolomiti è tanto la
letteratura perché quel senso di
bellezza che ci lascia qui spaesati
stamattina come ogni volta che ammiriamo
il paesaggio dolomitico è il medesimo
che ci lascia spaesati di fronte al
volto di una donna alla pagina
letteraria scritta da un poeta
letteratura e cammino montano hanno
molto in comune quando noi camminiamo in
montagna alla ricerca di una cima siamo
soliti seguire un sentiero già tracciato
essere in attento ascolto dei segnali
che potrebbero condurci laddove noi
vogliamo con fatica ma anche mossi da un
senso mistico di splendore per arrivare
lassù in letteratura non è molto diverso
quando siamo presi da qualcosa che ci
interessa all'interno di una pagina e
perché noi siamo in cammino verso una
cima seguendo un sentiero seguendo dei
segnali che altri percorrendo quel
medesimo cammino hanno lasciato prima di
noi
e allora ecco che le parole dei grandi
romantici sono tracce sono segnali sono
indicazioni che ci fanno muovere oggi
nel 2015
ancora su quel cammino uno dei più
grandi romantici il poeta inglese john
keats in uno dei suoi versi più celebri
scrisse che bruci struth proof of duty
la verità è bellezza la bellezza verità
questo è tutto quello che dobbiamo noi
conoscere sulla terra chi lo sapeva bene
la bellezza è qualcosa che ci appartiene
perché è reale e il reale quando è
davvero tale ci viene incontro
manifestandosi come bellezza non si
tratta come dicevamo di cose astratte ma
di cose che regolano i nostri rapporti
umani
c'è un valore civico nel riscoprirsi
romantici c'è un valore culturale di
scoprirsi romantici perché andiamo a
ripescare tutta una serie di concetti
forse dimenticati l'idea di fantasia
l'idea di cortesia
l'idea di bellezza e l'idea di assoluta
che proprio oggi viene messo a tema qui
sulle dolomiti e se uomini come lord
byron in inghilterra o holderlin e
novalis in germania alla fine
dell'ottocento erano attratti da luoghi
come questi e inneggiavano alla bellezza
di queste montagne
il punto è proprio questo allora non
interessava raccontare un paesaggio
carino che avevo ho visto bensì
raccontare quella traccia d'assoluto che
improvvisamente era capitata loro negli
occhi attraverso la rivelazione della
bellezza il romantico e questo è il
ribelle è colui che sfida il mondo
perché ha capito che nel mondo c'è un
significato ulteriore che non è
riducibile alla mera quotidianità al
fatto che il sole sorge poi tramonta noi
mangiamo andiamo a dormire ci deve
essere qualcosa di più se esistono le
dolomiti se esistono le dolomiti essere
uomini non è un semplice passaggio
terrestre è e deve essere una sfida ai
cieli in questo senso la bellezza di cui
parliamo oggi è davvero la bellezza di
cui si parlava william shakespeare che è
il padre putativo dal romanticismo
voi sapete che nella scena forse più
celebre di romeo e giulietta alla fine
del primo atto quando lo meo arriva a
casa di giulietta improvvisamente
dimentica una certa lo salina che nel
dramma non vedremo mai
e guardando negli occhi la giovane
montecchi da lontano pronuncia la famosa
battuta ma il mio cuore aveva mai amato
occhi rinnegate perché prima d'oggi voi
non avevate mai visto la bellezza
da quel momento
giulietta diventa il significante del
mondo
romeo si accorge che il mondo è diverso
perchè ha scoperto qualcosa che è troppo
bello per essere al mondo come le altre
cose e dunque tutte le cose hanno un
significato ulteriore giulietta vale per
romeo quello che le dolomiti valgono per
gli esseri umani sono cioè una sorta di
rivelazione di un assoluto che non
possiamo lasciar cadere e allora ecco
che il valore civico del romanticismo il
valore culturale del romanticismo ci si
fa avanti di fronte un passaggio come
questo con tutta la sua forza è anche il
valore didattico vorrei dire in
conclusione perché se noi crediamo che
essere romantici in questo senso sia una
sfida da cogliere da abbracciare e alla
quale rispondere anche la scuola alla
quale dovremo pensare una scuola diversa
che non pensa a meri obiettivi didattici
in maniera asettica per individui
supposti tutti identici bensì come vuole
il romanticismo si sofferma
sull'individuo su quelle che sono le sue
passioni le sue potenzialità e nella
luna noi andremo a ricercare proprio
quanto vi è di nespresso di
appassionatamente possibile attraverso
lo studio della bellezza e della cultura
spesso sono la stessa cosa
uno dei più grandi romantici goethe ci
diceva che camminare è il simbolo del
romanticismo grandi pittori gli faranno
eco friedrich con la celebre immagine
del viandante del mare di nebbia costa
bollo in inghilterra è l'idea del
camminatore della warner di quello che
in tedesco chiamiamo il wanderer assurge
a simbolo del romanticismo proprio
perché si tratta di un cammino faticoso
e meraviglioso che sfidate cielo e terra
riscoprendo la bellezza che le montagne
custodi custodiscano all'interno di loro
stesso una frase è rimasta celebre di
goethe l'europa è nata pellegrinando
perché nella visione romantica noi siamo
tutti peregrina cioè pellegrini a spasso
nel mondo alla ricerca di alcuni
significati e in questo particolarissimo
momento storico nel quale l'europa in un
altro modo inaudito e terribile viene
sfidata a riconoscere il senso del
pellegrinaggio a riconoscere il senso
dell'altro che arriva a noi in cammino e
in cerca d'aiuto e di un senso del mondo
io credo che un significato del
romanticismo legato all'essere
pellegrini come quello di goethe come
quello dei grandi romantici che stamane
abbiamo evocato se forse un significato
da mettere a tema e da riscoprire nella
bellezza di queste montagne
grazie
no